[WATER RUNNING]
[SQUEAKING]
[CHILD CRYING]
What we keep talking
about is, what
are scary, disturbing
sequences that we
can bring into the piece?
And the writers came up
with the hypnosis idea.
Count down slowly from 100.
99, 98, 97, 96--
If we did a hypnosis episode
where someone was put under,
we could get some more
nuggets about the cult, what
they experienced.
And again, did
they experienced it
outside of the house.
What did they experience?
You see a baby?
Does he have the baby?
He takes out of the eyes,
and he throws them away.
[PHONE RINGING]
Yeah?
Why is she looking for me?
Everything in this show
is an interpretation.
We represent supernatural
by insinuation,
which is my favorite
way of telling stories.
You just insinuate.
You never actually
see the shark.
It's just "movement in
the water" kind of thing.
[SQUEAKING]
Why haven't you told
her what she did?
[MUSIC PLAYING]